hurt opinion editor at the Washington
Times and a Fox News contributor
Charlie when Trump ran in 2016 he talked
about the corruption Corruption of the
swamp I mean yes
it's only gotten worse yet they continue
to cover for him
no it's incredible Pete to stop and
think about this you know what we have
seen over the last two years has proven
everything as if anyone was doubting
yeah what it was that Donald Trump was
saying about what was wrong with
Washington and in particular what was
wrong with the Democrat Party and at
that time especially the Clinton family
and Hillary Clinton uh it's all come
it's all you know every everything that
has happened since he left office has
proven that he is exactly right about it
the places is at least as corrupt as he
he warned us and probably with this
crowd is even more corrupt than it's
ever been before
um you know I I think that that that uh
interview with uh with Devin Archer is
so interesting where he wanders into the
thing talking about Icarus the uh with
the wax wings flying too close to the
Sun you know this the level of
corruption inside the Biden family it
was so profound it was so hot that they
had no it was like like like they broke
the meter of corruption because they got
so close and let's not forget it is you
know as as overwhelming as the evidence
is it's very simple
Joe Biden took a billion dollars of
American taxpayer money and took it to
Ukraine and bought his son a very
lucrative yes it's that simple and then
he's been selling out American foreign
policy ever since absolutely right and
then of course it's Donald Trump who
gets impeached for pointing that out on
a phone call that's how Washington
exactly D.C Works a perfect phone call a
perfect phone call by the way it reminds
me of when I remember when when uh when
Donald Trump started saying where's
Hunter remember that at the beginning
and everyone's going it gives you a
sense of how what an Open Secret the
Biden crime family must have been their
influence peddling over all those years
when Hunter Biden was nobody knew his
name uh yet Donald Trump knew he was on
to something then here's how they're
here's how the other side here's MSNBC
trying to deflect about what these last
few days have meant watch this
it will probably redirect the
conversation to President Biden's son
Hunter Biden who doesn't work in our
government we have seen it for months
and now this third Trump indictment has
started a new wave of what about ISM
from the GOP and the talking point is
out Charlie what about ism is the is the
new basically saying Donald Trump's
defense is going to be well what about
what about Hunter Biden what about Joe
they're coming after Trump and yet not
after them
yeah so it's interesting um Hunter Biden
supposedly doesn't work in in the
government but and and is not registered
as a lobbyist but apparently he does
work in the government because he's able
to get the vice president of the United
States and now the president United
States on the telephone to make deals uh
you know to make all of these corrupt
deals to benefit himself and his family
and keep the corruption going but I also
think it's you know Democrats play this
game like oh you know we really hope
that Donald Trump is the nominee because
we you watch out you watch what you ask
for Democrats because there is nobody
that has come on the scene in decades
who is a better prosecutor of exactly
this case and you're talking about
Donald Trump isn't want somebody he gave
up so much of his family uh you know the
the enjoyment of his family he he that
he had made a enormous uh reputation for
himself and he gave it up to serve his
country and then you look over here at
the Biden family they've been spent
their lives you know leeching off of the
government off of the American taxpayer
and by the way Joe Biden how many times
did he flame out trying to become
president because he was a liar
everybody in Washington knows he's a
liar he's always been a liar he's just
now the biggest liar there ever was
running a completely corrupt Biden
family
influence peddling corruption cards yeah
I mean Charlie I would agree with you if
you weren't such a dog face pony soldier
but otherwise you're spot-on in your
analysis yeah it's incredible Charlie
thank you great breakdown hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else